Ryan: Hi, there! My name is Ryan. I'll be your assistive tech user from fable today for the title and slug I'm participating in today. It is called Record a goose sighting 5, and then for the slug UOCI dash RGS.
Ryan: For my assistive tech. Today I'll be using voice control on. Ios sorry on ios on iphone 14 pro Max and
Ryan: for the voice control prompts. Today I'll be using show grid and show numbers prompt to navigate through of
Ryan: for the today's task. I will select a start. And now select. Start now and answer the questions with fake information. When I'm done I will be on a page where my answers will be revised.
Ryan: After this I'll try to change my answer up to the type of goose I saw, and then I'll complete my answers and submit the application.
Ryan: Okay, so I'm gonna go ahead. And first thing I'm gonna do is try and select. Start now and see if I'm able to navigate through. So right away I like how I see the start now. Button like very big and easy to see I'm not having. I'm not gonna have any issues trying to look for it or knowing where I need to go to next to navigate
Ryan: 14.
Ryan: So one of the issues here is that it thinks the the show numbers prompt is believe. It thinks that there are
Ryan: the Yes and the no headings are actual buttons itself as well. So that's why there's numbers overhead of it so that it think cause it thinks it's clickable as well. This makes it a little bit confusing for me, just cause it's covering with like the numbers. If you're able to extend down where the the actual Yes and no are so like, move it a little bit further away from the circle, or just make them bigger, so that they can match the size of the circle, and then
that number prompts won't cover over them.
Ryan: So I'm gonna go ahead and re remove the numbers for now. So then, I'm able to click. See what I'm able to click clicking on. Go to sleep.
Ryan: Okay, wake up.
Ryan: wake up.
Ryan: So do you like East 5
Ryan: Ninth.
Ryan: so that so far so great it's been easier navigate. I'm not having any issues with trying to differentiate which numbers are where sometimes, again, there will be numbers, course, but, like be on top of each other, so you won't be able to see what number you're supposed to actually say, so that the prompt clicks on whatever you need to nav to click on whatever wherever you are. At that moment.
Ryan: what type of goose did you see?
Ryan: Tell us what type of goose it was 5
Ryan: 5
Ryan: black spur winged goose.
Ryan: 6.
Ryan: Yeah, right there. It understood my voice properly. They didn't have any issues trying to understand what I was typing out there, and that seems seamless for me right there. There's a lot of issues I have when I'm trying to type out words in different types of form fields when saying them it gets a little bit confusing, or sometimes it will auto. It will go to the next form field without me actually clicking. Continue.
Ryan: When did you see the goose? So let's say, I saw it yesterday.
Ryan: 8,
Ryan: 28,
Ryan: 18
Ryan: 0, 3,
Ryan: 2024
Ryan: 19.
Ryan: Alright. So that was pretty easy again. I didn't have any issues I liked how, when it came to the month, I didn't have to say it. It seemed like I didn't have to say 0 3. Instead, I could have just said the actual number, and it would just accept that as it was like 3. It took it as 3 right there. one thing II said I was gonna use yesterday's date. But I just realized I was going through just to use whatever date. It's fine, and
Ryan: I didn't.
Ryan: I don't know if it would be easier to implement a calendar system for that it's hard to tell like for me like that process was pretty easy, so I don't think anyone else would really have an issue trying to go through with voice control. But you know, you never know there could be.
Ryan: in case we're like it doesn't hear properly, and it says the wrong thing. It types up the wrong thing, and then that makes it a big hassle for whoever's using it to delete it and then resay it. Sometimes they won't even delete all of it. So you could have some issues there
Ryan: other than that. I'm gonna just so go ahead and
Ryan: click. Continue. After reviewing this information. swipe up
Ryan: oop. there will be a page that will let you revise your answers. So yeah, this is the page.
Ryan: Yup, I believe everything I see is fine. I know that the date I picked is in the future, but
Ryan: you know, hopefully, they won't catch that 17
Ryan: 17,
Ryan: maybe.
Ryan: Oh, actually, you know what I think. I did something incorrect. I'm just gonna go back, if possible.
Ryan: swipe up. I'm just gonna see if there's a so easy way to go back instead of having to click the back when swipe up.
Ryan: Okay. so
Ryan: let's try by clicking on. Take a look at the answers. Think that should help
Ryan: 11
Ryan: swipe up.
Ryan: just wiped down. Yeah, I believe I'm in the I'm in the wrong area. So I just we had to edit out one of the
Ryan:  Add out one of the answers that I put. So I'm gonna just try seeing if I'm able to swipe down.
Ryan: swipe down
Ryan: scroll to top
Ryan: 3,
Ryan: 18,
Ryan: 15,
Ryan: eighteenth.
Ryan: Okay, there you go. Brought me back to this page. Got scared there for a second. Okay, so I'm gonna go ahead and change the type of goose that I saw.
Ryan: I don't know many goose. So I'm gonna just say something random. 10,
Ryan: 5,
Ryan: spider goose.
Ryan: 6.
Ryan: So assumes like you have to 8,
Ryan: 8,
Ryan: a 16,
Ryan: 17
Ryan: 16.
Ryan: So it's gonna be difficult to type numbers under a certain
Ryan: delete. All
Ryan: 17
Ryan: hide numbers
Ryan: 24
Ryan: show numbers
Ryan: 17.
Ryan: Hide numbers
Ryan: 12
Ryan: show numbers
Ryan: 18,
Ryan: 2024,
Ryan: 19.
Ryan: So that's where I think the calendar method is very helpful, because it, as you could see it thought like the numbers that I was seeing trying to type in the actual form field where the numbers that I was trying to
Ryan: where they thought it was the numbers that was trying to click on the actual, on the prompts that the show numbers was the voice control was showing. So that's why II think it would be easier to have a calendar for most people, so they can do that, or even a form dropdown menu drop. The menus are very easy to navigate the well, they can be at certain times depending on what type of dropdown menu. It is so.
Ryan: Okay. Now that I've reviewed, I've changed the answer.
Ryan: Let me just make sure I'm doing it on this page. Try to change
Ryan: as you saw after completing your answers.
Ryan: Okay? So basically, I think this is where I'm coming to almost an end. I just have to click.
Ryan: I have to click, continue. And this is where I can
Ryan: got. And the task
Ryan: so 16,
Ryan: yeah, so overall, the experience was, it's actually pretty easy to navigate. The only thing I can really bring up is that area where I was?
Ryan: with the, with the Ca, with the, with the the date that it was asking for it should I think a calendar would probably be easier. Or, again, a dropdown menu, just a specific drop down. Menus would be helpful. The way that I was going about it right now. You saw it was a little bit of a hassle the second time around, because it was corresponding with the numbers after turn voice control on and off this tedious task that
Ryan: I don't really want to go through while I'm trying to navigate there was also I also in, but I did enjoy how there was
Ryan: big areas to click on the radial buttons that you gave were, they were easy to see, but the only issue I had there was the Yes and No. They were hiding right behind the number prompts, so I was not able to see them. Yes, I could have just hid the numbers and then come back. But again, it's just that little tedious step that you know, you have to put in between. That's doesn't work too well.
Ryan: And then other than that. There was also one thing I other that I wanted to mention when I clicked on edit and I tried to change the date. I didn't like how it brought me after clicking, continue in that area the second time it brought me to the page where I have to retype where I saw the goose
Ryan: or sorry when I no, not when I don't know what it said. At the end it said something about
Ryan: where? Where did I see the goose, or when I saw it? I'm just might be confused. Oh, after changing the name, and then it brought me into the area with the date, which is when I saw the war Goose, which that's a little bit that was a bit tedious. I didn't like having to do that a second time. If I had the date already, and I'm just editing when it was, or sorry I'm editing what it was. I shouldn't have to go through the process of going through the steps again, so I was wondering if I click on the first one. Would I have to go through all the steps again?
Ryan: Other than that? Thank you for trying to implement accessibility and thank you for listening.